[Music]
foreign
already he just doesn't know it yet I
feel sorry for his family
nine seconds
that's what you have to decide your fate
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
that's what I'll give you to decide your
faith
[Music]
Roberto tell me what did you do back
home
government work I'm retired for you
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real people and I'm starting
to believe
this is where I'm supposed to be
foreign
[Music]
that's the median nerve but I'm
compressing
that's a level three you don't want it
to go to a level four
hey
seem like a man who understands violence
you can't take that from me
um I can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily did you kill him
[Music]
in seconds
do I look like a killer
[Music]